on YouTube
Ryan sends me a note he says Dave how
much money do I need to make a year to
be considered a millionaire Ryan a
millionaire is not a level of income
there's two measures of money or wealth
one is income one is called net worth
millionaire is based on your net worth
your net worth is what you own minus
what you owe equals your net worth your
assets minus your liabilities and so if
you don't have any debt your net worth
is simply the value of the things you
own and so if you save for retirement in
a mutual fund then you build up several
hundred thousand dollars there you've
got to paid for home that's worth
several hundred thousand dollars you add
those together and it's equal to more
than 1 million dollars with no debt then
you would be a millionaire so how do you
get a million dollars that's what it
amounts to that's what a millionaire is
well one way is to invest if you invest
from age 25 to age 65 at only a hundred
dollars a month if you were to average
about what the stock market averaged
about 12% you'd have one million one
hundred and seventy six thousand dollars
at retirement most people work making
money from 25 to 65 and most people make
enough during those years to save a
hundred dollars a month if they didn't
spend everything they'd make so that
would make you then a millionaire if you
had a million dollars in your mutual
funds in your retirement account not to
mention the other items that you've done
along the way so it really doesn't take
a lot of income to become a millionaire
if you start early and if you're steady
that's what it amounts to now you can
actually have a negative net worth and a
lot of people do a negative net worth is
when you owe more than you own
for instance you owned a home that went
down in value for whatever reason the
neighborhood was bad
or something happened in the town or the
area that caused the property values to
go down and and it's the only thing you
own is a house that you owe $400,000 but
now it's worth three hundred thousand so
you owe a hundred thousand more than you
own you'd have a negative net worth of a
hundred thousand dollars at that point
so net worth is one measure of wealth
and it's the most lasting one because
your income comes and goes depending on
your job your career your business that
you own whatever it is it's creating the
income net worth is much more stable
much more substantial so you want to
have a high income but it is more
important to have a high net worth and
that'll get you to where you want to be
because again if you've got that size of
a pile of money the income that that
pile of money creates starts to be
enough to support you without you
working and that's what some people call
financially independent I don't usually
use that term but when you have enough
of a pile of money in your net worth
that it creates more money than you make
then I actually call that the pinnacle
point when you built you when you go
over the top of the hill and that's
where you have enough money that your
money now makes you more money than you
make you now that's a substantial net
worth and that's usually more than a
million dollars depending on what your
income is and what your career is and so
forth
so that pile of money as you build
wealth gives you stability gives you
income you could have a bunch of rental
property that's paid off you could have
a big pile of money in mutual funds and
your 401ks and Roth IRAs and that kind
of thing
doesn't matter where the pile of money
is or if it's some mix of those is what
it usually is that pile of money - your
debts which hopefully you have none if
you do what I teach is your net worth
and when that is equal to 1 million
dollars you're a millionaire that's how
much money you need to have to become a
millionaire but it is not how much money
you make a year you can there are people
actually that make a million dollars a
year and spend it all and they have no
net worth it's hard to believe people
would be that stupid but I meet them
sometimes they're professional athletes
sometimes they're people in the music
biz
sometimes they're just people that hit
the lotto but I meet people who make a
million or more a year and spend every
bit of it and have absolutely no net
worth now we would all say that's
wasteful and ridiculous and it's easy to
assume that if we got there we wouldn't
do that but what you've got to do is you
have to set yourself to say no matter
what I make I'm always investing no
matter what I make I'm always giving and
that will create your net worth cause
your net worth to grow and your net
worth is the stability factor it's what
real wealth is when you talk about a
wealthy company a wealthy family a
wealthy whatever
no one's ever talking about their income
they're talking about what they actually
own which becomes your net worth and
that's where your millionaire status
comes from